You know there,
there's,
there's good study published recently
showing that six month old infants,
I think it was six month,
are already showing fear of snakes and
spiders and that's before they've been
exposed to them,
so there's not an argument about amongst
psychologist for a long time,
whether fears were only learned.
Thought would be the behavioral
perspective,
whether you're prepared to learn certain
fears,
which is sort of a mediator between the
behavioral perspective and a perspective
that takes into account inherited
structures or whether they're actually
innate and the evidence keeps accruing
that some of these fundamental fears are
innate and that's a very strange thing.
More more hardware than firmware,
if exactly that.
Exactly.
Well and metaphor and I mean the,
the,
the archetypes,
the symbolic representations we have say
of Reptilian predators.
Dragon in particular are very,
very deep.
That dragon is a symbol that you find
everywhere in the world.
There was a good book written about that
recently.
Actually.
I'm the guy who wrote the book,
whose name I can't remember,
unfortunately thought that a dragon was
a cat snake bird and so well on.
So because the major predators of of
tree dwelling primates are predatory
cats,
snakes and wrap doors,
right?
And Keyword.
There's,
in my opinion,
the way I'm interpreting it is tree
dwelling.
Like that's how far back $6.
Million
nears least.
Yeah.
So on that.
So at least $60,
million years.
It could,
it could be longer than that,
but snakes and human beings,
snakes and the ancestors of human beings
co evolved.
And Lynn is.
Bell has demonstrated that down and you
know she's a,
she's a scientist and in with,
in the California state system,
I think she's at Ucla and she was very
interested in white human beings have
such a cute vision.
And so she did a study looking at the
relationship between primate acuity of
primate vision and presence of predatory
snakes and found a pretty powerful
relationship.
And so.
And we can really detect snake like a
camouflage patterns,
particularly in the lower half of our
visual field.
And so yeah,
these things are.
See the way it looks to me is that we
develop this Predator detection system,
right?
What's in the unknown Predator?
What's the Predator?
It's a cat snake bird,
which is exactly what it is.
Right,
and you think,
well,
that's not a category.
It's.
Yes,
it is.
It's a low resolution category that
apply.
It's the same category as Predator.
That's right ad from a cognitive,
anthropological perspective,
which is sort of,
again,
the way I tend to look towards things.
It's actually the most functional
categories.
Absolutely,
because it all the relevant elements.
That's right.
If it's more differentiated than you
have to make the assumption that you all
will automatically know what's about to
attack you,
what you don't know,
the unknown.
That's right.
So it's a cat snake burden.
It breathes fire and you know that could
be a reference to the poisonous to a
poisonous snake,
but it also could be the inclusion of in
the dangers because of course fire was
certainly a danger on the velt at
certain danger in the forests.
And so fire breathing,
cat snake bird covers a lot of
territory,
but it's even better than that because
you say,
well,
what's in the unknown?
So you project the contents of your
imagination into the unknown to fill it.
But the thing is is that we're not just
prey animals,
we're also predatory and exploratory.
And so the Dragon,
the cat snake bird that breathes fire
isn't only a Predator,
it's also the thing that guards virgins
and the thing that guards gold.
And that's also fascinating because I
think that the,
the are the ancestral males who were
good at,
at keeping the cat snake bird at bay.
We're much more likely to propagate.
I mean,
that's just seemed self evident I think
when you tell people that everyone
thinks,
well obviously,
you know,
and that's the gladiatorial type or
maybe the person who went out and found
out where the nests of these things were
in,
got rid of the nests.
And,
and then.
And so we also,
we have this bifurcated image of the
Predator which is the Predator slash
unknown,
which is also the place of new useful
things.
And so when it's very,
what would you call it?
It's very articulated,
almost like in the Mesopotamian story,
one of the names for Margo who goes out
and confronts Tiamat,
who's basically a cat snake bird is he
who makes ingenious things out of the
body of Tire Matt.
And I mean,
how can you,
you can't get any more direct
illustration of the idea than that.
And when he has battled with ty Matt,
who's come back with all the monsters,
there are including the king of evil out
there at their forefront to destroy that
society of the Gods.
He cuts her into pieces and makes the
world.
And so it's perfect.
That's the,
the,
the uh,
the savior of humanity,
let's say,
is he who confronts the chaotic unknown,
differentiates it and makes the
habitable world.